I fell in love with the idea and
especially with the fact that people
told me it will never work it did work
and the rest was history and then I met
another uh
person a great guy whose name is Norm
Bardin uh who spoke with me about the
voice of her opinion and we said great
let's do it and people thought we are
crazy we're sitting in train stations or
airports and speaking to a computer
because we came with this assumption
that phone calls are extremely expensive
and if we will if we'll be able to do it
over the internet then we reduce costs
and we did it by the way
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this incredible journey that that you're
on I mean just going over the incredible
projects that you've done and putting
aside the financial upsides and I'm
putting aside you know the titles and
the recognition the technologies that
you've been a part of and the pioneering
work of breaking barriers and and
breaking you know conceptions and glass
ceilings uh it's a it's something that
I'm very excited to to hear your story
and thank you for giving me time I know
you're very busy and and so I really
appreciate these 20 minutes with you and
so I the only thing that I can ask is
you know tell me your story thank you
for being here
oh thank you it's a great pleasure so
you know just I will start with an end
in the beginning so today I'm an agent
that already amazing company very deep
level of AI in a way similar to
generative AI with 19 patents developed
by two amazing professors uh one of them
got golden age of Science by President
Clinton for this work today our
technology and I tell you more about the
company later monitors 11 billion
transactions a year more than one
billion
customers and overall about 15 trillion
dollars helping financial institutions
all around the world to move money
in a much more secure way and in a way
we created the category leadership in
the new category called category called
trusted Global Payments but it started
some time ago I was seven and a half
years in the Israeli military
some might say too many years and and
one of the things I was responsible
there is bringing the internet to the
an IDF when I left a
the military internet was just the
beginning so we built a company called
that Vision which became I think the
largest internet service provider in
this region I always joke that it was so
new people said that it's so
unnecessary Israelis couldn't even
pronounce the internet for those who
know negro they said they used to say
entertain which sounds much more
Hebrew wait wait Mark I I we can't just
gloss over this you know the story of
net Vision you're you're sitting here in
the 90s and you're in Israel and you're
a post IDF and there's this thing called
connected world the World Wide Web it's
just starting you know what's happening
I mean I you know this is I know a lot
of people who are around in the 90s I
don't know many people who were directly
involved with you know with with helping
this thing scale to the masses what was
happening there so I think that they
always had this weakness to practical
Technologies because it was a great
technology I love the research but I
found the way you know that the world
can be much better and more convenient
place I thought about the fact that I'm
sitting television I find they can
easily connect to New York that time it
took only two minutes so obviously chat
was not possible to send an email and in
addition I really love converting a
monetizing technology and I believe that
if technology can solve a real need then
what the monetization is easy so that's
how it started it really excited that's
a big that's a big statement if you're
if it's technology is monetization is
easy it sounds like sort of like like an
axiom that you've taught yourself in the
back of your head what stands behind the
sentence
so I believe that people are willing to
pay for Value if people get real value
and
they will do it and Technology should
solve some Gap some real need sometimes
pain sometimes desire that people will
be willing to pay because the money that
the payment will be in their view less
valuable than that what they're getting
obviously the biggest challenge is
taking the technology finding the right
product Market fit finding where is the
desire and then providing exceptional
level of service now I love technology
especially technologies that come from
the
defense applications such as the AI
we're using right now such as Internet
that time because on one hand it's crazy
people think that it will never work so
there's less competition let's face it
you know I don't want to work too hard
with a competition and on the other hand
if the technology has been proven in
some defense applications then the high
chances are that the technology is
working also we'll talk a little bit
about Talent about people I can trust
about people that are better than me can
help me if they already using this
technology somewhere in this case in the
area of defense then it will be easier
to find great talent that will support
me
okay so so back back to back to
netvision taking back to the 90s New
Concept inter10 in Israel and we're
we're scaling it up what's happening
there
absolutely so I fell in love with the
idea and especially with the fact that
people told me it would never work it
did work and the rest was history and
then I met another uh
person a great guy whose name is Norm
Bardin uh who spoke with me about
Voiceover IP and we said great let's do
it and people thought we are crazy we're
sitting in train stations or airports
and speaking to a computer because we
came with this assumption that phone
calls are extremely expensive and it
will win if we'll be able to do it over
the internet then we'll reduce costs and
we did it by the way suddenly people
from Afghanistan could speak with a
Bilal in Pakistan without paying eight
dollars a minute which was like a
monthly feather but people thought they
were crazy like sitting and speaking to
a computer by the way if you think about
it Michael that's what you and Dad win
right now so it's mainstream the same
ways internet became mainstream uh voice
over P became mainstream the company
went public everybody was happy
and then obviously Great Value nice
monetization and again this is now a
mainstream technology
wow okay and so taking for a second
putting a spotlight on these two these
two cases what was common about them is
that they were both Pioneers in in
consumer behavior and and then you had
to climb over some some glass ceiling or
or climb over Summer Hill
can you reflect back on what that felt
like you know being an entrepreneur on
something that could be other people are
looking at and saying why do we need
this or this doesn't really make sense
this is not mainstream
yeah so you know I started pretty early
and I get used to the fact that people
will look at me and tell me look kid you
don't really understand hey nobody needs
it B it doesn't really work and see even
even if people need it and it does work
nobody would buy it from you some big
guys will be able to take over your
market and they're just not giving up
and bringing people inspiring them
showing them the vision
showing them what's possible and then
slowly but surely if you don't give up
and you provide good service
it becomes a reality and you know I can
take a third company
and it's also and you know sort of
making use of the opportunities we're
now speaking in uh just the beginning of
2023 just uh we're in the midst of the
crisis and Churchill said that it's a
shame to waste a good crisis so if you
remember
in late
2002 a big crisis.com collapses and
there was bunch of capacity satellites
in the sky and we decided to take a
bunch of satellites move them over
Africa in the Middle East and bring
secure Satellite Communication to those
areas now I've never been to Africa I've
never been to the Middle East that time
and you see my smile I really enjoy
doing things that I've never done so we
moved there and within few years the
company became 100 million dollar
Revenue company extremely profitable by
the way there's a rare situation where
startups distribute dividends to the
shareholders but we also made the world
a much much better place yes we
connected Banks allowing them to make
more money we collected governments
allowing them to produce a better
service to the customers but one story
that really has inspired me that time is
the customer called matcha malaria well
a paying customer and we connected them
to the internet and when I visited them
they told me the story about kids that
mothers broke from all over Africa with
malaria and usually they were taking a
blood sample sending him sending them
once a week over the plane most of the
cases was impossible getting answers
within a month which is human you can
imagine was too late and suddenly they
have internet connectivity satellite
connectivity they got donation this
beautiful machine that makes Blood
Simple and transmits the results the
World Health Organization within minutes
and then within a day 24 hours they can
get an answer and save kids so you know
building a company that's extremely
profitable distribute dividends but also
saving lives it's a big bonus it's a big
a very nice combination and
and again it was making the impossible
possible obviously became a really great
ill and operation and then I took a
company that works in the world of
intelligence Services a little bit more
classified and helping governments that
collect so much information to find bad
guys you know historically it's not a
secret
uh Snowden discovered that governments
were sort of listening to your phone
calls and you know trying to transcribe
them reading your sms's but now the
situation is totally different and
different you have WhatsApp and Facebook
and the LinkedIn and the passport and
you name it so the amount of information
is endless and it was clear that human
beings cannot deal with it anymore
so that's what I discovered the world of
AI and
we did the amazing job it was a
turnaround it turned the company around
from Lost leader to a profit leader sold
it to one of the largest defense
companies and in the world I would say
the great outcome
and as I said I love taking the step of
Technologies and moving them to the
world of Commercial Services so that's
how I was introduced to these two
amazing professors
by the way I think I do have a vision
unfortunately I don't think that I have
great technical ideas I always find
great smart people that bring the
technology bring the idea and I try to
help them to do customization to do a
monetization of that technology my
passion is to convert technology into
money and value of
um so I made this two amazing professors
who created amazing amazing technology
to identify believe it or not cancer
using blood samples obviously it wasn't
the right product Market fit but they
literally managed to mimic the intuitive
way their experienced doctors work and I
said look that's exactly what government
agents is working for let's take this
technology and build a company and of
course nobody believed at the beginning
that it's possible so we had to solve
very painful problems we don't do it
right now well the first problem we
solved was helping General Electric to
protect nuclear facilities
if you're familiar with staxnet stories
Etc
how to discover sex and such as tax net
attack you know you need to understand
how centrifuges work now obviously we
don't want to help Iranians but it's a
long story and we don't have time for
that but eventually stocks that what
discover was discovered and an Iranians
attacked aramco against cyber security
attack it was JG customer they needed
some solution we helped them to solve it
and then later on Singapore Airlines
approached us we found solutions to some
threats with the airplanes making nice
money but it wasn't scalable but at
least we could show that it's working
and then we did a very
thorough work trying to see where is the
Real Pain where we can really help and
which organizations would be living
willing to pay for it and we found of
course that the world of payments and
the world of financial institutions it's
a best place for us to provide value and
that's what we do right now so it was
almost a monologue already I will stop
here and let me know I'll let you answer
some questions
I I have about a million but that's
that's the truth but I'm already writing
them down for me to ask you in person
when we're gonna meet very soon as we
discussed that now I'm mailing it in but
now you've done it foreign
that's it that's it uh I want to spend a
few minutes I know we need I also want
to talk about Federate but I want to to
talk about cyber and AI you know what's
happening you've you've LED cyber
divisions and multinational companies
with billions of dollars under
management you're now leading an AI
company that's all about creating trust
in this new environment what is the con
what's happening with cyber and AI as
you've experienced over these last few
decades these things sort of
intersecting so here's the really cool
stuff and the those who listen to this
podcast guys you are living in the best
time possible because the same
Revolution that happened to the internet
and 23 years ago is happening now for 10
financial institutions if you think
about it
cyber criminals started by defacing
websites you know stealing some
information but now it's all about money
they would like to make money and they
sell and then send send those phishing
emails hoping to make some money Etc
you know I made a very interesting panel
moderated very steeper interesting
partner with heads of police departments
including the Interpol cyber department
and was a clear understanding
that the most profitable job in the
criminal world and the safest one is to
be Financial cyber criminal because you
see it somewhere in a remote place
nobody sees you you steal money from
financial institutions and if they get
you or catch you they just you just
disconnect the line and disappear
so I think that today 99 of financial
crime
is basically cyber Financial crime yes
it involves a little bit of social
engineering but the best is to sell to
to steal the beats and you know people
think that when we talk about digital
currency that it's ethereum or Bitcoin
or other cryptocurrencies but no today
dollars and checkers and Euros are all
digital there are more
digital dollars then printed dollars and
there's much less gold so if you think
about it especially with postcode 19
nobody goes to a branch of a bank with a
M16 or Uzi or some weapon and pride to
shoot or scare the clerks you just take
into account move money steal money by
the way it's also the same in the world
of
governments they need to finance their
activities North Korea started back into
the Swift Network and stealing 80
million dollars to finance themselves
there are Russian sanctions right now
people thought it's a nuclear option
they will disconnect Putin and there is
no way it will be able to transfer money
we all see him buying drones drones from
Iran selling oil because as my one of my
customers said Swift is a very limited
network uh putting many transfers money
doesn't say first name Vladimir last
name Putin address 100 Square Moscow so
the people who cannot do business on
Swift others poor little guys big guys
know how to circumvent it and now is a
punchline so Swift the 50 years solve
network is exactly where the internet
was when people suddenly realized that
your IP address is not secure and your
email address is not necessary
identifier and then there was a need to
create firewalls and checkpoint was
established Etc now we're facing exactly
the same situation with financial
institutions it's difficult to move
money there is no trust and that's why
companies like territory flourish by
basically building this a firewalls that
can monitor Financial transactions
to trust
creating trust
um in this new world what does that mean
for you
so
think about yourself trying to transfer
money from one country to another by the
way did you ever try to do it personally
yeah it's it's a long process it's a
long process it's a nightmare it will
cost a problem
Thirty forty dollars it will take two
three days yeah it's crazy it should
take five seconds it costs five cents
it's digital it's like it's less data
than an email with an attachment
and it takes so much time because it's
dangerous let's assume that you are in
United States and they want to transfer
money to somebody in Nigeria
how your bank in the United States know
that this person Nigeria is a genuine
person and how the recipient Bank in
Nigeria knows that you are great a guy
which is you are Michael and not some
human trafficker they don't so they
created a lot of policies and procedures
that make it very very difficult for
banks it's very scary because if they
fail then they pay huge amount of fines
billions of dollars and it doesn't
really work so they try to go through
the risking which means that they will
reject the cows they will make life hell
for you and that's what all the people
seen without totally changed it we
understood that and the same is in the
world of Internet there was a relevation
that your IP address is not really a
good identifier and your email address
is also also not a good identifier there
is a need to look at each and every they
call it packet in the internet each and
every transaction and identify is it a
valid or not is it kosher or not we did
the same for financial institutions
and again when we said we're going to do
it people said it's impossible because
the normal way to create trust was what
they call kyc know your customer so
you're going to a branch of a bank show
your idea they know who you are the guy
in Nigeria goes to their Bank show their
idea and they know who that person is
and if somebody would like to create
fake ideas it was possible but it was
difficult if you want to open 10 million
accounts now it's all digital now it's
all on the web now it's all online so
today I don't really need to print 10
million fake IDs we just hack into some
bank that is on a switch Network create
10 million accounts and then each
account will transfer
only ten dollars but if you have 10
million accounts although each account
will transfers them transfer the money
under the radar you have 100 million
dollars and moving in
so yeah that's what we did people
thought it's impossible it was one
entity can transfer millions of
transactions we said it's possible and
we said we're gonna get our AI to do it
and today
we're working a guy in a gulf as well in
UAE so I can say inshallah we said
inshallah people will accept us and
alhamdulillah
people did accept us the largest box of
the world is working with us fintechs
Etc
and I and as you can see I love this
impossible stories uh because of the
technology because of the acceptance
because of the value and especially
because of the people that do it with me
because you understand it I need to find
people that are better than me
professionally and that's crazy as me
when it comes to going through these
obstacles and being Unstoppable
that's uh amazing Mark I'm already
booking you for another episode to
diving into a few of the items that
you've brought up but these were 20
amazing minutes uh all the way starting
back from this idea of you know being a
Pioneer for these Technologies
overcoming these obstacles providing
inspiration for those around you and
then seeing those Solutions implemented
in the wild and seeing them you know
grow to become some Staples of of
mainstream society and and the
Transitions and evolution that you've
made in the Cyber and AI space and
obviously today with what you're doing
uh at the the most Cutting Edge scene of
fintech and Ai and trust and so things
that I'm deeply
um excited and passionate about and so I
really thank you very very much I
appreciate it if I can add one last
sentence because I know about your
passion
and the way you see I I have to say
something many people tell me what
Monica this is such a powerful AI isn't
it dangerous and I just want to say one
thing
um
you know every new invention people said
it's dangerous when a print was created
people said that's it it's the end of
human memory when a phone was created
people said that's it we will not meet
each other anymore when internet was
created everybody told me look you will
not understand the language of your kids
and in a way it's all true but let's
face it it brought so many good things
and then the world of AI I think because
bad guys have been using AI for a while
and they are using it we as good guys
have an obligation to build AI that will
become our digital guard and we'll make
our life in everybody's life better and
much safer and thank you for the
opportunity to say it
[Music]